Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonsoir.
Je vais vous raconter l’histoire du petit
Médor, un petit labrador blanc.
Son maître le prend
et le met dans une cage électrifiée.
Il lui envoie régulièrement
des décharges électriques.
Médor essaye de s'enfuir
mais il n'y arrive pas.
La cage est barricadée.
À force,
Médor s'assoit et attend juste
que la sentence passe.
Il n’essaye plus de sortir de cette cage.
Son maître prend un deuxième chien
et le met dans une cage
électrifiée pour moitié :
une zone électrifiée,
une zone non électrifiée.
Il prend le chien
et le met dans la zone électrifiée,
envoie une décharge.
Que fait le chien ?
Il passe le petit muret qui le sépare
et se met à l’abri.
Ouf ! Il va beaucoup mieux.
Le maître s’intéresse maintenant à Médor.
Il le prend et le met
dans la cage électrifiée pour moitié
le pose dans la zone électrifiée,
envoie une décharge.
Et que fait Médor ?
Il s'assoit.
Il attend juste que la sentence passe.
Il n’essaye même pas
de passer le petit muret
qui le sépare
de la zone [non] électrifiée.
Il a assimilé la cage à l'impuissance,
à l'impossibilité de s'enfuir.
Suite à cela, le concept
de l’impuissance apprise est né.
C'est le psychologue Martin Seligman
qui a mis cela en avant en 1964.
Je vous laisse dix secondes
pour vous demander si vous avez déjà été
confronté à l’impuissance apprise.
La réponse est oui.
Notre cerveau nous joue des tours
et plus particulièrement avec la lecture.
Lorsqu'on était ado, on nous a donné
des lectures obligatoires.
C’est à ce moment
qu’on a commencé à assimiler la lecture
à quelque chose d’ennuyant.
On a -
On nous a demandé de lire du Voltaire,
du Victor Hugo, du Balzac
pour le contrôle de français,
pour tout simplement avoir une bonne note.
Le plaisir de lire a commencé à s’évaporer
et inconsciemment,
après le bac de français,
on a tous fait le vœu de ne
plus jamais terminer delivres.
Jusqu’à mes 29 ans, j’étais comme ça
et rien ne me prédestinait
à devenir un grand lecteur.
J’ai redoublé le CP.
Mon père ici présent a été convoqué
par le directeur de l’école
parce que j’étais trop nul, d’après lui.
J’avais du mal à lire, à écrire
et, en CE2, on voulait me mettre en SEGPA.
Heureusement que mon père a dit non.
J’ai passé mes mercredis et mes samedis
chez l’orthophoniste
et j’ai eu le bac de justesse.
J'ai fait plein de petits boulots pendant
un an et ensuite j'ai repris les études
et je me suis battu, battu, battu.
Et il y a quasiment
dix ans jour pour jour,
j’étais dans cet amphithéâtre
à cette place-là.
Je suis devenue ingénieur
des Arts et métiers.
(Applaudissements)
[C’est] une fierté pour moi de revenir ici
et vous partager ma passion.
Quand j’étais jeune, je pensais que je
ne pouvais pas terminer delivres.
Jusqu’au jour où j’ai osé aller à pied
à cet atelier de lecture.
J’ai osé aller au-delà
de mon impuissance apprise.
J'ai trompé mon cerveau.
Ce n’est pas parce qu’on a échoué
une ou plusieurs fois
qu’on ne peut pas essayer
encore et encore pour réussir.
C’est la découverte de nouvelles méthodes
qui nous permet d’aller au-delà
de notre impuissance apprise,
d’admettre qu’à quelques
mètres de nous, tout est possible.
Que faire ?
Un pas de côté peut nous permettre
d’enlever des schémas ancrés
depuis des dizaines d’années.
Aujourd’hui, je suis vice-champion
du monde de lecture rapide,
triple champion de France de mind mapping.
J’ai des élèves champions du monde
et je suis devant vous pour vous parler
de ma passion qui est la lecture rapide.
Qu’est-ce que la lecture rapide ?
Comme le nom l’indique,
ce sont des techniques qui permettent
de lire plus rapidement.
La plupart des gens lisent
moins de 200 mots par minute.
Ils sont considérés comme
des lecteurs lents.
Rien de péjoratif, c’est juste une
dénomination dans le monde de la lecture.
On a les lecteurs moyens qui lisent
entre 200 et 500 mots/minute
et on a les lecteurs rapides
qui lisent plus de 500 mots/minute.
Depuis que j’anime des conférences
et des formations sur ce sujet,
j’ai pu accompagner
plus de 100 000 personnes
et 90% d’entre elles lisent
en-dessous des 200 mots/minute.
Pour vous donner un ordre d’idée,
un enfant de CM2 qui doit passer en 6e
lit environ entre 120 et 150 mots/minute.
Beaucoup d’adultes lisent
comme des enfants de CM2.
Pourquoi lire plus vite ?
Pourquoi progresser ?
La lecture est un support incroyable
de connaissance.
Les livres nous ouvrent les portes
du monde et de la connaissance.
En lisant plus vite, on peut lire un,
deux ou 3livres par semaine,
apprendre des nouvelles compétences,
des nouvelles connaissances.
C’est très utile
dans le monde professionnel
pour lire nos mails, nos rapports, nos
documents ou tout simplement nos cours.
On lit presque 4 h par jour à nos dépens.
Imaginez ce que vous pourriez faire
si vous lisiez beaucoup plus vite.
Vous pourriez utiliser ce temps
pour lire des livres intéressants,
pour passer plus de temps
avec les gens que vous appréciez,
pour travailler beaucoup plus vite.
Ce qui est incroyable,
c’est que notre soif de savoir
peut être assouvie grâce
à des techniques très simples.
Je vais vous demander de vous lever
(Brouhaha)
et de vous mettre par deux, par binôme,
et de vous regarder dans les yeux.
Chacun se regarde, vous vous mettez
par deux et regardez-vous dans les yeux.
Ok, vous pouvez dire à votre binôme
qu’il a de beaux yeux.
Si ça vous intéresse, vous pouvez dire ça.
Non ! Tout le monde m’écoute !
Revenez avec moi !
L’exercice est simple : la personne
à ma droite est la personne A
et la personne à ma gauche
est la personne B.
La personne A doit faire un cercle
avec ses yeux, un petit cercle
et la personne B l'observe.
Allez-y, ensuite, je vous donnerai
la consigne d’après.
Ok ?
Maintenant, écoutez-moi.
La personne B fait un petit cercle
avec son doigt
et la personne A doit suivre le doigt
de la personne B et faire son cercle.
Allez -.
Et maintenant, vous changez.
Faites dans l’autre sens.
La personne B devient la personne A,
et inversement. Allez-y.
C’est bon ? Tout le monde a fini ?
Vous pouvez vous asseoir.
Alors -
En parlant de technique, la lecture rapide
se pratique toujours avec un guide visuel,
un appui - ça peut être un stylo,
ça peut être son doigt.
Vous venez de le constater, les yeux
font naturellement des saccades.
Le cercle était beaucoup
plus fluide avec le doigt
que lorsque la personne
l’a fait sans appui.
Naturellement, nos yeux ont tendance
à regarder en haut, en bas,
à droite, à gauche.
Donc lorsqu’on va lire,
on va utiliser un appui -
notre main, un stylo -
et on va suivre tout simplement
notre lecture avec notre appui.
Plus notre main va aller vite,
plus nos yeux vont aller vite.
Ça va vraiment être un ancrage
pour nos yeux.
Ce qui est incroyable, c'est que va lire
comme un enfant de CP qui apprend à lire
et également comme les champions du monde
qui utilisent cette technique.
Le guide visuel peut nous
permettre d’augmenter
presque de 30% notre vitesse de lecture.
Je vais partager une 2e technique.
Je vais vous demander
de vous lever une deuxième fois.
Ok. Maintenant, vous allez
regarder devant vous.
Regardez bien devant vous. Mettez vos -
Levez vos deux mains.
Levez également l’index.
Regardez devant vous,
levez la main droite,
baissez la main gauche,
regardez toujours devant vous.
À un moment donné, vous n’arriverez
plus à percevoir vos doigts.
Dès que vous n’arrivez plus
à percevoir vos doigts,
vous revenez au milieu.
Dès que vous ne percevez plus
vos doigts, revenez au milieu.
Ok. Maintenant, vous faites la même
chose de manière horizontale.
Faites attention à ne pas mettre
de claque aux personnes à côté de vous.
À un moment donné,
vous ne percevrez plus vos doigts.
Ok, dès que c’est bon, vous revenez
au milieu et vous pouvez vous rasseoir.
On vient de constater que,
grâce à notre vision périphérique,
on peut voir à 180 degrés
et on voit beaucoup mieux
de manière horizontale que verticale.
En plus du guide visuel,
lorsqu’on va pratiquer la lecture rapide,
on va créer deux marges imaginaires
dans notre livre.
Ça veut dire quoi ?
Ça veut dire qu’on va réduire
tout simplement -
On va réduire tout simplement
la quantité de texte à lire.
On va faire abstraction du premier mot de
la ligne et du dernier mot de la ligne.
Et notre guide visuel va se balader
uniquement entre les marges.
Ce qui est fou, c’est que notre cerveau
ne va pas lire le premier mot de la ligne,
ni le dernier mot,
mais de manière inconsciente,
notre cerveau capte l’information.
Je vais vous mettre un petit texte
et　je vais vous demander de le lire.
C’est bon pour tout le monde ?
Ce message est bien difficile au début,
mais vous avez réussi à le faire.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que notre cerveau est très puissant
et il nous joue régulièrement des tours.
Pour finir, je vais vous mettre
une vidéo avec un texte.
Je vais vous demander de le lire
pour voir votre vitesse de lecture
et tester votre vitesse.
Allez-y !
[Test de lecture rapide
Niveau très facile 150 mots/min]
[3 2 1]
[Le but de la lecture rapide
est de retenir les informations]
[sinon cela serait trop simple.]
[Vous avez peut-être déjà été dans
le cas où vous étiez en train de lire]
[puis vous n’avez pas été
capable de mémoriser votre texte.]
[C’est normal,
que vous lisez rapidement ou lentement.]
[Niveau normal - 350 mots/min]
[3 2 1]
[Un lecteur moyen lit entre 200 et 250...]
[Grâce à un certain nombre de...]
[un lecteur rapide lira entre 400...]
[Il sera ainsi capable de lire 1...]
[et d’atteindre
la connaissance illimitée.]
[Niveau avancé - 550 mots/min]
[3 2 1]
[Lorsque vous développez
votre capacité à apprendre...]
[votre carrière
et votre croissance personnelle...]
[Niveau difficile - 750 mots/min]
[3 2 1]
[Inaudible]
[Nous vivons à l’ère
des voitures électriques...]
[votre esprit vagabonde
lorsque vous essayez de vous concentrer.]
[Niveau expert - 850 mots/min]
Ce n’est pas fini.
[3 2 1]
[Aujourd’hui, j’enseigne...]
[Parce que la chose la plus importante
dans laquelle vous devez...]
[Niveau des illimités - 1000 mots/min]
[3 2 1]
[Un mind map est un schéma...]
Ok.
Certains se sont arrêtés
à 350 mots/minute, d’autres à 550.
L’important, c’est de savoir
d’où je pars pour savoir où je vais.
Lorsque l’on veut pénétrer le monde
de la connaissance illimitée
et utiliser son plein potentiel cognitif,
il faut admettre que tout est possible
et arrêter d’écouter la voix qui nous
murmure à l’oreille que c’est impossible.
Impossible d'apprendre.
Impossible d'être meilleur.
Impossible d’apprendre l’anglais,
de changer de métier,
d’avoir mon diplôme d’ingénieur.
Impossible de réaliser mes projets.
Impossible de réaliser mes rêves.
Il faut enlever la notion d'impossible
de notre cerveau.
Il faut tout simplement utiliser
son cerveau comme une Ferrari
et non comme une calèche.
Si aujourd’hui je suis devant vous,
c’est pour vous partager ma passion,
mais également une idée simple :
que tous ici présents,
nous devons, et nous pouvons,
apprivoiser notre impuissance apprise
pour réaliser nos rêves et réaliser ce
qui nous habite au plus profond de nous.
Je n’aurai jamais pu réaliser tout cela
si un jour je n’avais pas apprivoisé
mon impuissance apprise
en me répétant une phrase toute simple.
Est-ce que vous souhaitez
que je vous partage cette phrase ?
Public : Oui !
Je n’ai rien entendu.
Est-ce que vous souhaitez -
Public (fort) : Oui !
Je me répète tous les matins :
« Mohamed,
pour avoir ce que tu n’as jamais eu,
il faut faire ce que
tu n’as jamais fait. »
Une variante de ce que
Albert Einstein disait :
« La folie, c’est de faire
toujours la même chose
et d’espérer un résultat différent. »
Je suis Mohamed Boclet
et je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)